My name's Lynn Wright.
I'm customer service team leader,
and I manage repairs and reproofs.
I'm now going to walk you through
how our team restores a Beauchamp jacket.
It's an older-style jacket.
We don't do this jacket as much now.
I think it was made in 2005.
The jacket has a rip on the
right side of the front,
and the button needs replaced.
The jacket looks like it's dried out
and it hasn't been rewaxed for years.
Barbour jackets are waxed
so that they are water-resistant.
Over time, the wax will wear off,
so we recommend that they are sent back
to be rewaxed every year to
keep it resistant to water.
Firstly, I'm going to give
it to one of me operators.
Julie-Ann is given a job sheet
to go along with the jacket.
And we'll take the old button off.
We use an unpick. An
unpick's a little tool
that you just carefully
unpick the threads,
and it loosens the button off.
And we'll measure the fabric
out for the size of the patch.
And then we'll fold the patch
and we'll actually mark around
the area where it's ripped.
We cut the patch a bit
bigger, about a centimeter,
just in case as we're repairing
the jacket it does rip more.
So, we'll mark it.
We'll place the jacket in the machine,
and we'll edge-stitch the patch
where we've done the marking.
The old button has a crack in it,
so we're replacing it
with a brand-new button.
We'd sew that on,
hand-sewn, with a needle.
There's normally four holes in the button,
so we'll go from each corner,
crisscrossing the thread,
and then we'd wind the
thread round the button
to secure the button and then
snip it off with our clippers.
We now check for quality,
and we'll hang it on the rail,
ready for midline inspection.
I'm going to take it over to Neil,
and he will rewax the jacket
and bring it back to life.
Firstly, Neil will pick up a scoop
and fill it with hard wax from the drum
and place it into the heated pot.
The wax is melted at a temperature
of no more than 60 degrees.
Otherwise, it will be too hot
and it will go through to the lining.
We remove the garment from the rail
and position it onto the table.
We will apply some fabric into the jacket
to protect the lining.
He'll now zip the jacket
up and fasten any buttons
or press studs on the front of the jacket.
Neil is now ready to
start the rewax process,
which, he'll use a sponge
to apply the heated wax round
the parts of the jacket,
using a consistent approach.
Neil uses long gliding strokes
for the application of the wax.
It gives it a better finish.
As Neil is applying the wax,
you'll see that he doesn't touch
the new fabric on the repair,
as that's already got a lot of wax in it.
The rewax table is also
heated at 60 degrees.
So the combination of the heated wax
and the heated table helps blend the wax
into the jacket to bring it back to life.
As you can see, Neil has
now done half the jacket,
and you can see the difference
of when the jacket's reproofed
and when it hasn't been reproofed.
Neil has now finished the wax-on process
and will now begin the wax-off process.
Neil will use a dry cloth
to take any excess wax off the jacket
around the seams, studs, and the buttons.
Finally, Neil will unzip the jacket
and remove any fabric he's put in
to protect the lining,
check the lining is clean
and is in perfect condition.
When the rewax process is finished,
we do allow the jacket
to be hung up and dried
for anything from 30 minutes to an hour
before we dispatch.
The jacket will now be
sent out to the customer,
who will be very happy with
the outcome of a jacket
that's been restored,
repaired, and rewaxed,
and they'll be able to
wear it for years to come
on their adventures in the outdoors.